hi I'm Madison and I'm a senior in high
school I'm Vanessa and I'm a preschool
teacher hi my name is Ted I'm a creative
writing teacher I'm Ricardo I'm a senior
we'll be doing a teens versus teachers
take the same math course probably gonna
fail
[Music]
I used to be pretty decent at it in high
school I got into a calculus class like
my senior year but then I decided that
since I didn't need it I would drop the
class I would probably give myself a
d-plus in math I give myself B at math
my best math is probably geometry
because I have like an artist mind so
like shapes are kind of my thing
geometry with like shapes and stuff like
that I'm like I just can't do that's
just it it's mentally challenging on me
you know passing a math class in general
is just accomplishment in itself okay if
I can like get a C and like even a D
I'll be happy I'm pretty good at long
division
hopefully I pass I'm ready say your
prayers
let's do it all right question number
one solved for X square root of 45 minus
4x equals 500 okay no I got this okay I
don't even know where to start with this
actually a circle that you know I used
to get in trouble for not showing my
work all the time and I'm not gonna do
it deal with it she's already smoking me
I am confident with the length of the
rectangle is 10 feet less than double
the width the perimeter of the rectangle
is 64 feet what is the area of this
rectangle so the perimeter there's a
formula for this like area equals length
times width yeah is that right how are
you doing are you doing good writer who
knows what is coordinate of the point of
the slope of the line if yes where did
you guys get these questions who slopes
I'm looking forward to that I remember
doing slope and I remember not doing
well with them so
hmm my goal is to get at least one right
I was like oh it's slope I know slope
rise over run and then I realized I have
to put the coordinates into the slope
how do I do that
MX plus B what does that mean again not
though I feel - hold on I'm actually
doing kind of okay on this I think I
think I got the general idea of this one
he pays 60% of the bill it's a sixty
over a hundred and twenty-five more than
J nope
all of the formulas I remember are
failing right now I like this one it
just says x equals one there's no word
cylinder whatsoever that's fine
X my favorite question was what figure
it out this is literally so embarrassing
I am like wanting to tap out but I'm not
I'm not gonna tap out yet I swear I used
to know how to do this f of X equals 2x
squared minus 5x evaluate F of negative
3 is this real math so X minus 3 over 2
equals x plus 9 over 5 oh I can do this
okay and then I have two equations that
I have to use so this would be plus 15
plus 15 x equals 7 piece the top an out
Talon out if we're doing something I'm
doing nothing she's doing something I'm
doing nothing I'm just writing I'm gonna
say five dollars and then put a sad face
next to it because I'm pretty sure
that's incorrect I'm never coming back
to BuzzFeed if they indicated these are
right angles or not but they're probably
not right angles I said it was good at
geometry I'm a fraud here comes that
long division everybody am I looking at
close your strong suit you will thrive
for long division work together I'm
gonna say 6 9 69
[Music]
two big fat zero this isn't an
accomplishment like hey it's better than
me
how many did I'd even get right I think
I just got one too that was that's so
that's give that too that's like one and
a half yeah it's close enough counts
right I'm gonna say I got two right I
thought there would be simpler questions
honestly these were pretty tough I do
not want to try this again
look what did we learn here today not
much nothing at all and I don't know why
I did this I'm glad I did this with you
though I feel like if I did this another
teen or god forbid a math teacher I feel
like we could relate we could relate to
each other more I'm glad I did this with
you because you're done with math
[Music]